behavior is a language
so often we try to get people to talk to
us and they don't talk they don't have
the communication the ability to talk we
say hey will you sit down and talk to me
you sit down and talk to me and really
through their actions they've been loud
and clear
and in a situation like this I can ask
like hey I want to talk to that guy see
if your marriage is over
or behavior is a language he is being
very clear
he has no interest in being married to
her he's interested in having someone to
sleep with every once in a while he's
interested in having a a live-in
housekeeper he is not interested in
being married or having a wife doing
life with somebody
behavior is a language